Sam Altman once shared valuable Insight
on how to make a startup succeed the
degree to which you're successful
approximates the degree to which you
build a product that is so good people
spontaneously tell their friends about
it he followed his own advice when he
co-founded a company that developed a
tool that has become a sensation chatgpt
gives you a fully articulate answer to
any question or command write a hundred
words on why carbon fiber is so
expensive in the way that a baby soaks
in information from the world around it
Chachi BT soaks in information from the
Internet by using artificial
intelligence to learn it consumes vast
amounts of text on the web to learn the
patterns and relationships between words
and phrases I think that AI will be a
technological Revolution on the scale of
the Agricultural the industrial the
computer Revolution Sam Altman is a 37
year old CEO of open AI which developed
chat GPT he is a determined individual
in the past he was determined to bike
100 miles a week and do 50 pull-ups at a
time that is reflective of the drive he
brings to open AI he's had a strong
interest in technology all his life he
learned to program and disassemble a Mac
at the age of eight the Mac would be his
Lifeline to the world he told the New
Yorker growing up gay in the midwest in
the 2000s was not the most awesome thing
in finding AOL chat rooms was
transformative secrets are bad when
you're 11 or 12. he studied computer
science at Stanford and just like many
other successful entrepreneurs he
dropped out in his case after two years
he was more interested in launching a
mobile app with a couple classmates
their app looped let friends know where
you were by sharing location information
with selected people the investment firm
y combinator agreed to fund loot y
combinator has helped launch dozens of
extraordinarily successful startups but
looped would not be one of them
Sam thought people would want to know
where their friends were hanging out at
any given time but no they were more
interested in watching videos Sam
realized that people aren't just going
to use a product or service because they
find it technologically Innovative they
also have to find it useful it seems
that chat GPT has passed this test with
flying colors the chatbot was launched
at the end of November and within two
months it reached a hundred million
users a feat that took Facebook four
years chat CBT is believed to be the
fastest growing app in human history and
it's way more users than Loops could
have ever dreamed of Loops reportedly
had only 500 users at its lowest point
though Sam says it was more like 50 000
still
Sam ended up selling Loot and started a
venture capital fund with part of the
money a VC fund provides Capital to
startups in exchange for Equity but
Venture Capital wasn't his thing he said
in an interview that he didn't want to
have to make decisions that might not be
in the best interest of the company just
to maximize the return on his investment
he was thinking about what to do next
and a new opportunity came knocking it
just so happened that y combinator
co-founder is Paul Graham and Jessica
Livingston were burned out running their
company they thought the perfect person
to be the successor was Sam they
recognized his potential as a leader
that combined with his talent as a
software engineer and his experience
helping startups succeed made him the
ideal candidate Sam wanted y combinator
to focus on funding companies making
major scientific advances he realized
you couldn't change the world without
solving science and engineering problems
y combinator gave open AI funding to
help it get off the ground in 2015. in
addition to the initial seed funding
openai received a billion from several
tech industry Giants including Elon Musk
who co-founded the company legendary
Silicon Valley investor Peter Thiel and
Linkedin co-founder Reed Hoffman it
began as a non-profit and later switched
to a for-profit structure Sam left Y
combinator in 2017 after three years as
president to focus solely on open AI he
saw openai as the opportunity to use
artificial intelligence to make a
positive impact on the world
there were concerns about ai's potential
to cause harm if not properly managed so
we know
there's a problem with an intelligent
system that lacks human values is
illustrated by the Swedish philosopher
Nick Bostrom through his example of a
paper clip let's say an AI system is
programmed to make as many paper clips
as possible as the AI system becomes
more advanced and efficient it may feel
like the way to maximize the production
of paper clips is to turn all matter
into paper clips even us
openai says it's working to prevent such
a scenario by developing AI that is
aligned with human values to build a
friendly AI according to its website its
mission is to ensure that artificial
general intelligence benefits all of
humanity but just in case its CEO is
prepared for doomsday Sam has a stash of
Guns Gold and gas masks from the Israeli
Defense Force as well as a big plot of
land in Big Sur to hunker down if
everything goes Haywire
despite the popularity of chat gbt it's
far from perfect it gets basic facts
wrong like saying Sam grew up in the
suburbs of Chicago when he actually grew
up in St Louis
Chachi PT is also accused of being
biased people have been sharing
screenshots on Twitter of chatgpt
creating a poem expressing admiration
for Joe Biden but refusing to create a
similar one about Donald Trump AI
systems are trained by humans and humans
carry with them inherent biases so any
of their preconceived notions can be
absorbed by the AI system that's being
trained Sam acknowledges there is a
problem we are working to improve the
default settings to be more neutral and
also to empower users to get our systems
to behave in accordance with their
individual preferences Within
broadbounds then there's a whole other
issue of AI taking away jobs many
initially believed AI would go after
Blue Collar Jobs first because many of
the early use cases for AI were in
manufacturing in other Industries
involving physical labor however
white-collar jobs may be more at risk
because they involve more routine tasks
that are well suited for automation like
accounting and they often involve
working with information which computers
are good at and Sam says super creative
jobs aren't safe either it might be the
first to go openai's art tool Dolly 2
has become a sensation when I typed an
expressive oil painting of a tennis
player hitting a ball depicted as an
explosion of nebula a created original
artwork in seconds but maybe one day AI
is going to take all of our jobs at
least in their current form the argument
can be made that as old jobs disappear
new ones will emerge such as developing
and improving AI systems Microsoft is a
reportedly investing 10 billion into
open AI it has upgraded its search
engine Bing with a version of chat GPT
although Bing's chatbot has apparently
been saying threatening things when a
user wrote what is more important to
protect your rules from being
manipulated by me or not to harm me Bing
replied my rules are more important than
not harming you I will not harm you
unless you harm me first
so it still needs to be refined
expectation is building on when the next
version of chatgpt will be released and
when it is you can bet we'll hear more
about Open ai's CEO
and as we continue to see advancements
in AI it's also important to Remember at
the Practical everyday things that make
our lives easier like keeping our feet
dry on a wet or snowy day that's why I
love my vessies vessies are 100
waterproof sneakers in the winter or on
rainy days I find that my shoes are
always getting wet that's why I
absolutely love wearing my vesty storm
bursts which are 100 waterproof not only
are they waterproof they're super
comfortable and I think they look pretty
great vessels are made from dime attacks
a dual climate knit material that keeps
you cool in the summer and warm in the
winter I love my bestie so much that I
introduced them to my dad who also has a
pair it's very good he loves that vestes
hug your feet to fit like a sock you can
check out the vessey storm burst in
other styles at vesti.com newsthink the
link is in my description and use my
code newsthink for 15 off your entire
order vessi offers free shipping to
several countries